[موسيقى]
نحن هنا في ينابيع Strawberry Park الحارة
أو خارج Steamboat
Springs مباشرة ، على بعد حوالي 15 دقيقة بالسيارة
من وسط المدينة ولدينا 40
فدانًا هنا وهناك بعض من
أفضل الينابيع الساخنة حول
[الموسيقى]
لدينا  طورت الحديقة بأسلوب بسيط للغاية
حيث ترى
الجدران الحجرية تتدفق الجداول التي تجري
بجوار حمامات السباحة وكل شيء منظم
بطريقة غير رسمية للغاية نريد الحفاظ
على الجو الريفي الذي نريد أن
يكون الناس قادرين على الاستمتاع بالينابيع الساخنة مثل  إذا
كانوا في بيئة طبيعية في
مكان ما في وسط الغابة
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
- ملابس اختيارية بعد غروب الشمس ، لذا
عندما تأتي ساعات الليل
نتأكد من عدم وجود أطفال في الجوار وأن
الملابس اختيارية لا  لديك أي
أرقام محددة حول عدد المرات التي
يتم فيها الاستفادة منها ولكن تمت الموافقة عليها من
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هناك سبعة ينابيع مختلفة على
الممتلكات ، حيث يخرج الربيع الرئيسي
من الأرض عند 150 درجة
ويغذي الحجرة  بركة السباحة التي لدينا هنا
خلفنا نقوم بخلطها في مياه الخور
وهذا هو التحكم في درجة الحرارة
ومياه كولد كريك التي نستخدمها لمعرفة مكان
درجة الحرارة التي ستكون
ساخنة جدًا بالنسبة لك ، أهم ما يميز
العقار وما نريده من الناس  تعال
واستمتع بالمسبح بالتأكيد ، لكن
التدليك هو فرصة ممتازة
خاصة بعد يوم شاق من التزلج أو
ركوب الدراجات في الجبال في الصيف ، لدينا
غرفتان لطيفتان للتدليك
مبنيتان في الجدران الحجرية بجانب التل ، إنها
تجربة مريحة حقًا رائعة
لذلك  نسيت
[موسيقى]